in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, from May 13th, on which we commemorate the Holy Martyr
Glyceria.
On the 13th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Martyr Glyceria and of St.
Laudiceus, the Jailer.
In the first year of the reign of Antonius the Pious in 138, there lived Entrezianopoulos
a young Christian, the daughter of a high-ranking Roman officer who devoted herself to confirming
the Christians of the area in their faith.
On the day of a pagan feast, she marked her forehead with the sign of the cross and went
to Sabinus, the governor in the temple, openly confessing that she was a hand-made of Christ.
When Sabinus ordered her to sacrifice to the gods, she approached the idols and confronted
the statue of Zeus with the invocation of the Savior, breaking it into pieces.
The pagans fell on her in fury and attempted to stone her, but the stones did not reach her.
They hanged the servant of God by her hair and tore her flesh with iron nails.
Then she was thrown into prison and left with no food or water for many days, but an angel
of the Lord brought her food and fortified her in the hope of good things to come.
Also when the governor summoned her again, he was stupified to see the saint come before
him in good health and radiant with confidence in God.
Before leaving the city to go to Thracian Hadaklia, Sabinus decided that Glyceria should
accompany him.
She was received with deference by Bishop Dmitius on the Christians, who had been told about
her valorous battles.
After appearing before the tribunal again, she was condemned to be burned alive, but a heavenly
dew quenched the furnace into which she had been thrown.
The judge then had her scalp torn off and she was taken to prison to await further torture.
This time, another angel came to succure her.
In the face of such signs from heaven, the jailer, Laudiceus, was converted and was immediately
condemned to be beheaded.
The saint was finally thrown to the wild beasts, a raging lioness lept at her but suddenly
stopped in its tracks and began tenderly to lick her feet.
Another lioness bounded forward in its turn and with a gentle bite that made no mark allowed
Saint Glyceria to join her heavenly spouse with joy.
The judge perished miserably shortly afterwards, while the bishop went to bury the body of
the valorous athlete of Christ not far from the city.
A vast and magnificent church was later built there in which Saint Glyceria was venerated
by all the inhabitants of the city, of which she had become the holy patron.
A relics were later translated to Lemnos.
From her head, however, which remained in Heraklia, there continued to flow a holy balm that,
like a spring of living water, healed many pilgrims.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.